- I think this should be pretty easy.
(playful music)
(gentle music)
This is harder than I thought.
- I think my son was trying to trick me.
- I don't know, this is tough.
- This one is Zeke's.
You can tell what it is,
but it's also kind of sloppy.
(laughs)
(buzzer)
Oh, was it this one?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- Oh, that's so funny.
- The clock that my son has in his bedroom
is a digital clock, so I'm going to choose
the only digital clock of the bunch.
(bell rings)
- The one with the most color on it.
Yes!
- This one.
The reason why is because I know
she knows what a clock
is, but I don't think
she knows where the numbers go.
(bell rings)
She's my kid.
- The one that looks most
like a type of creature
he likes to make up is this one.
(bell rings)
- This one?
(screams)
- I feel like she would label it.
Also, the mixed colors.
(bell rings)
- I'm gonna say this one.
And I don't really have a reason.
I just think it is.
(buzzer)
Is it this one?
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] Yes, it is.
- Oh, son, you're gonna kill me.
- It's between these two.
- This one?
(buzzer)
No!
Oh my god, I can't believe I got it wrong.
- I know that he can
draw better than this.
So I think he was trying to trick me.
I will guess this one.
(bell rings)
- I'm gonna say the
green one because I think
she likes green apples more than red ones.
(bell rings)
- This is really hard.
I think maybe this one?
(bell rings)
Thank you.
(chuckles)
I love you, Zeke.
Good worm in apple.
- I am very surprised that
I got one of these wrong.
- The surprise is that he
didn't try to trick me.
I think he tried to use
some reverse psychology.
- I felt like I was gonna know.
It threw me off having two
kids at similar levels.
- Zeke did throw me off a
little bit on his pictures.
I don't know if he did it on purpose
to try to trick me so
later on he could be like,
"You know, you really hurt my feelings,
"but some new Pokemon cards
would really make up for it."
So I'm a little disappointed in myself.
I might buy you some guilt
Pokemon cards after all.
(laughs)
Oh, man.